today we're talking about Health Equity
Google Cloud deploy and the security
updates from September I'm Sarah and
welcome to this week in Cloud where we
serve you the lowest latency news
Google is committed to helping everyone
everywhere be healthier as part of the
global Health Equity Community we have
an opportunity to ensure our products
services and research help everyone live
healthier lives
in keeping with that goal we recently
announced the Google Health equity
research initiative designed to improve
health outcomes for groups
disproportionately impacted by Health
disparities or negative social and
structural determinants of Health learn
more on the blog Google Cloud customers
want to be able to easily deploy their
applications to the full breadth of
platforms that we offer including Cloud
run and when they push out code to
production they want confirmation that
the deployment was successful that's why
we're excited to announce the preview
availability of cloud run targets and
deployment verification for Google Cloud
deploy head to the blog to learn more
as we head into October don't forget to
check out our monthly post from the
cyber security action team for
September's Edition we're focusing on
the acquisition of mandiant and what it
means for the broader cyber security
community
you can also hear more at Google Cloud
next happening this week and mwise
mandian's inaugural conference from
October 18th to 20th and of course we've
also got a Roundup of the latest updates
products services and resources from our
security teams check out the blog for
more details and to sign up
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud